[Music]
so there I was woke up with a heavy case
of amnesia in the middle of nowhere the
only clue to my past is Harry's name and
address inside this hat so I made my way
to be partnered and that's what I found
you
thank your stapler Colusa nation so your
otaku Pikachu with no memories is
addicted to caffeine I could stop
whenever I want these are just choices
another round extra shot I don't know
maybe hair got in too deep and mixed up
the wrong crowd that kind of thing you
could talk to humans I can talk to
Pokemon and if you want to find your
pops we're gonna need you no I don't
need a Pokemon what about a world-class
detective Harry is still alive case
closed
but still open until I solve it all
right here it is Harry faked his own
death or somebody else faked Terry's
death
[Music]
yeah Harry fake somebody else is dead
that last one doesn't work
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now obviously I've dealt with this pups
before so I'll just do it again hey bud
what are you doing I can't do when
people are watching
[Music]
that's a twist
no he's barely moving don't tell him
that
oh he's on a fight quick get in front of
him stop oh no he's going down hard Tim
should have worn a helmet some people
move on without us
not us
[Music]
[Music]
bring me the land
your life begins now
[Music]
Aladin
[Music]
you really don't know who I am genie
wishes land none today I ring it about
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow this place is amazing what a buzz
gonna meet us here he must be held up
somewhere hey up here Astro Boy if you
think you can take our top prize spot
your room dead wrong help me get out of
here there goes my toothpaste I am tired
of this
[Music]
go get the stick I'm done I'm done
living on this frozen still infested
islet we're gonna need a bigger
slingshot
[Music]
[Music]
why did you make me do that look at me
focus on my voice I'm not giving up on
you Jean she was my friend
you're my family James no matter what
look
you're special gene
and if you stop fighting that force
inside you
to embrace it
he will possess the very power of the
pie
she'll kill us all tell me how we fix
this trust tell me what to do now don't
know what you're doing
no they don't understand they fear and
what they fear we seek to destroy
it's your fault Charles tries to protect
her I'm scared
you and I lose control bad things happen
to people I punch the girl dies she's
still Jean we can still help her
sometimes you want to believe people are
something that they are not
no determine velocity they are
it's too late
she's coming
[Music]
be sure sir
very sorry about your loss
I can't even imagine how you must feel
your children
we've seen our safe now I thought they
heard her crying and they feel this
thing of reduce
they will
and she will come for that
I don't know the church works with
people who specialize in the situation's
language gets a lot your honor is she
coming she's all right here facing an
evil
it has no bells
[Music]
[Music]
every year millions of dolls are created
perfectly designed to bring joy to
people everywhere but what happens to
the dolls who are so perfect
[Music]
welcome to ugly veil friend wake up box
I've always believed the big world is
real I know I'll find the perfect kid
for me but I'm starting to wonder with
no evidence no prude what if it's not
true
find your own truth this is the way to
the big world how do we get up
[Music]
[Music]
what's perfection
is that excellent he's the most perfect
one here let me break it down welcome to
the Institute of perfection where only
the best will meet their perfect human
match you're an engineer slash model my
accessories will make me different or a
lawyer slash model I'm an individual
exactly like the rest of you do you
honestly think your little band of sock
puppets stands a chance to you they're
probably better if you just go back
where you belong are we really not good
enough for the big world no our flaws
make us unique those are all worth
fighting for
oh you do know that Lou is gonna make it
super hard for you well I say bring it
on Lois
[Music]
bless their ugly little hearts crazy
jenos
what's your name wedge head I love
literal naming isn't that right
gibberish cat
Charlotte I would like to endorse you to
be the next president of the United
States oh my god you've been a great
Secretary of State which state again all
of them looking at us I kinda know her
it's like kind of knowing a mermaid do
you tell people in analyzing Remember
Who I am
secretary field I'd like to speak with
you with me I can't shake this feeling
that we know each other we do we do
picture me I guess maybe like 20 years
younger but like this
Barsky yeah what are you doing these
days I'm a journalist you're a great
writer but sometimes you're a little too
much I'm the perfect portion okay
you boys didn't just call me a cracker
what is the relationship exactly it's to
babysit for them you babysat for him Wow
time has not been kind
I need some writers to punch up my
speeches what's writing is really good
and he knows me oh I feel so scared I
know right better for you I should kind
of get to know you better and if you
have a minute I'm actually up seven
seven minutes in heaven what is your
favorite book as a kid The Velveteen
Rabbit fair job must have been loved by
rocks a most embarrassing moment
what's your favorite sexual position
normal placing what's your favorite
sexual position
don't be gross Brad do a date I mean who
wants to follow me around the world and
know if I have five minutes to be
affectionate yeah we actually did almost
die we need to move you Thank You agent
them it's pretty woman but she's Richard
Gere and you're Julia Roberts honestly
this is the best few weeks of my entire
life
we a thousand constituents how they
would feel if Kate Middleton miss every
one of us were to start dating Danny
DeVito pretty negative reaction
but last time you got I was in doctors
[Applause]
I offer you a glimpse of a legendary
creature lost in time neither ate nor
man but a giant he's had many neighbors
actually I go by Susan Susan yeah Susan
that is a girl's name yes that's correct
it suits you I need someone who knows
the wild places of the world and you're
the world's greatest adventure exactly
answer me I'm lonely
I'm the last of my kind but on the other
side of the world they talk of this
creature the Yeti I think these yetis
are my cousins you take me there I give
you my word okay what is it what your
word it's a figure of speech sounds good
what is it well M on we have a long way
to go you'll need a map Harvey Bravo
thank you now to find the place you
belong you'll need to keep a low profile
[Music]
oh boy that is gonna let in an awful
dress so let me see if I understand do
you plan to travel around the world to
the home of the Yeti I know the secret
ways through the mountains you'll see
come whatever you do do not mention that
[ __ ] no chicken got it zip hmm
greetings venerable Gamu it is an honor
what's with the chicken it will not be
easy but we will find it your place
Shango ma we call it
what does it mean keep out we hate you
throw me out of the pit I think you
might be a little too heavy nonsense now
give it all you've got
oh it's hard to know whose fault that
was let's do it again tell me a story
it's a story about journeys the journeys
we take to prove ourselves
it's about the inventions
it's about potent magic magic beyond
anything anyone has ever [ __ ] before
but what it may serve and to be loved up
courage
it's about fellowship
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in the woods today
la discovered a charming little land
work but that sanitary place to bury our
pets and remember them which seems scary
but it's not perfectly natural
just like dying is natural whole town's
been using this place for generations
folks make a kind of ritual out of it
it's not some campfire story so these
are the trees up there they're warnings
the local tribes carved in before they
fled they fear that place there's
something up there something that dates
way back
those would to something else something
that cat was dead it brings things back
[Music]
I know what you're thinking of doing but
they don't come back the same wit scoyoc
you daughter I should never have shown
you that place your child is not the
only thing that will come back
the barrier is broken
we have a second chance sometimes debt
is better
hi I'm just I'm looking for a check
mm-hmm who's asking John chef jr. your
son my son jr. yeah
you know they say that cat shed is a bad
mother stretching now you know him he's
black James Bond that dude was real you
think he was me investigation I want the
baby sit your ass never long enough lady
syphilis
madam chlamydia it's lovely to meet you
both it's juniors well it's a little
bitter please tell me that you did not
get our son involved in your [ __ ]
you picked up a bat you can't beat up a
woman
why not because she's a woman that's
like misogynistic you won't be
misogynistic I mention agenda okay I'm
an equal-opportunity ass
ridiculous
right such you okay
yeah
[Music]
bought back in a day we didn't need guns
all we needed was all bare-knuckle Heil
Grampa oh you can't be too prepared
[Music]
you back there having an iPhone
oh hell de la shut it damn right what's
up
[Music]
[Music]
what does America mean to you your
removal is final there's nothing you can
do this is my home New York is my 13.8
billion years ago the Big Bang created
the Stars the planets the galaxies air
time life span of the universe our lives
begin and
[Music]
not all of them I don't believe so no
magic no fade no meant to be what if I
told you I could get you to fall in love
with me
just give me a day an hour when your key
ingredients to fall in love my
ingredients our friendship chemistry The
X Factor what's the X Factor don't worry
we've got time did you just call me Pat
time lad time my family's from Korea in
that tiny way that is not what I said so
you can stop waiting for apology oh I'm
waiting for something but not for an
apology
[Music]
ah
now I don't know
[Music]
but I think I could love what are you so
afraid of
listen I wasn't born here what my family
is believing tomorrow this is real and I
know you feel it too
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
don't have forever
[Music]
we have is a single day
[Music]
you